when the second level is you sit down
and you discuss the ground rules again
before you get too serious once you're
already moved in and married and now you
to discuss ground rules that's too late
so my wife and I had a very long
detailed discussion this was several
years ago and I laid out all the
negatives of being married to me and
non-monogamy was pissed off there was
like four or five and that was just one
matter fact the one she was scared about
was that I work a lot I work every day
she's like well you didn't care about
that on and on because I'd already been
doing it the whole time she met me so
she was used at that point it was more
like well you're gonna work a lot you
never gonna spend of time he was more of
that kind of stuff but you lay all that
stuff out and then you lay out the
ground rules and you're very specific
about the ground rules based on what
you're capable of and what you think
you're not capable of emotionally you
just don't go hog-wild
before she's my what hey girlfriend who
are thinking about getting serious we're
gonna be non-monogamous here the
parameters but here's what you can't do
you can't bring guys over and [ __ ] them
on my couch that I'll throw up you gotta
be honest about that stuff
I'm joined by Caleb Jones from all the
way from the other side of the Atlantic
how are you today I'm good how are you
very good man very good very glad to
have you on lots of interesting stuff to
speak about you have got the largest
tankard that you're drinking out of that
I have ever seen what is that
you know I drink a lot of water and so I
would have these little cups by my desk
and was there ever big enough so I was
like I gotta get a [ __ ] you know I
got a good tanker I gonna do something
real what does that that's like it what
litre and a half are you guys would call
it like a gallant leader in half yeah
just water be cool to this vodka but
it's not yeah I like some Mead it's a
big game of things yeah I don't drink
I've never been drunk in my entire life
so I just it just makes me look cool
when I drink my water I guess that's an
interesting lifestyle choice why did you
choose to do that you know I don't have
an answer for that question I wish I had
an answer I wish I had some kind of cool
story like well my parents were
alcoholics and no my parents were normal
and here's my guest so when I was in
seventh grade seventh grade so it's
about yeah about 12 I took one of the
cans of beer out of my dad's
refrigerator and I took on the side of
house and took a little coffee cup and I
filled it up and I promised myself I'd
drink the whole beer because I want to
get drunk because that looks like a lot
of fun yeah I made myself drink the
whole beer oh this is Darrell I wait I
can't wait til I get drunk I kept
drinking and drinking and then nothing
happened I just felt dizzy for a few
minutes and I think maybe that was it I
don't maybe I'm guessing I'm also an
INTJ for myers-briggs those myers-briggs
personality types okay yep so I'm an
INTJ I'm an extreme INTJ so my little
dot is in the far upper corner and the
INTJ is in the far upper corner of the
sixteen personality types so not only am
i am i an INTJ I'm an extreme version of
an INTJ and so one of the aspects of
most INTJs not all of them is that I'm a
control freak over myself but I don't
want to control anybody else so I'm
thinking that sub this isn't conscious
yet maybe subconsciously I don't want to
lose control of myself by getting them I
understand I think it I don't know
that's a gift I really don't know I'm
gonna have to do it at some point yeah
like you guys drunk once alright I'll
get drunk once it's a so I'm not
months into 18 months sober right I'm a
club promoter by trade so I've run
nightclubs for 12 years and that's been
merge calmly you're nine months in nine
months sober yeah but this is the I've
done six months twice and I'm doing nine
months now just to see if I can my
argument is that I work in the nightlife
industry I've worked around about a
thousand nights in my career across the
last decade and a bit so if I can do it
other people can and on top of that as
well do you wait do you consider
yourself an alcoholic or no no no so no
ed Lattimore have you heard of Ed yeah
yeah so I'd podcast with Ed and he
synopsized alcohol and people's views of
sobriety better than anyone I've ever
heard before and it's this sentence
alcohol is the only drug where if you
don't do it people assume you have a
problem yes
no one's saying to you why you're not
shooting up with heroin today why have
you not got a massive line of cocaine on
your desk behind you
but alcohol so ingrained in our society
that people just say you're not drinking
you must have a problem with alcohol
that's the right reason that anyone
would choose to go so but whereas for me
I was a typical sort of social drinker
go out maybe once every fortnight by the
club promoter drinker right so when you
go out you got hard like you were it's
straight are mean spirits in your mouth
in a nightclub it says oh that's awesome
yeah exactly and I just about two and a
bit years ago I wanted to do more with
my life I wanted to have a lot of
experiences already to travel more I
wanted to start this podcast I wanted to
push my business and my fitness and my I
wanted to develop a reading habit in a
meditation habit and all these other
things and I looked at my time as if it
was a set of accounts and saw that there
was this big day and a half cost getting
chopped out of my full night fortnight
period one day hungover and then a half
a day at maybe 50% capacity and then you
finally get back on to it so I honestly
think it doesn't surprise me that you
have a lot of irons in the fire
considering you've never
been knocked off with a hangover like
the only time that you'll be like that's
if you're ill yeah that's pretty much it
I've wondered about if I was a typical
drinker or even a heavy drinker cuz I've
got some of those guys in my family
where I would be today as opposed to
where I am now and also how I would look
how my skin I'm 47 so how my skin would
look now cuz that's a steak for 47 well
I moisturize
that's the key ladies and gentlemen
moisturize early yeah my eye there's an
old Doctor Who line
the girl says you're 900 years old seems
like why moisturize moisturize yeah but
I know I have buddies who are my age
I've known since high school who are you
know not even big drinkers just but
regular drinkers and my god you can see
the difference even guys don't get a lot
of Sun like me and they still like Wow
or smokers to smoking the other one
smoking and drinking has never smoked
anything either
yeah I smoked it I smoked some weed once
for about three seconds yeah so what I
had to learn how to do was to drink wine
I'll sip wine mmm
because for what you're talking about I
would sit with a group of people or even
on a first date with a woman and they'd
be drinking and I'd have nothing or my
water why don't you treat they people
get uncomfortable yeah especially
everyone else is drinking or not
especially including if you're one on
one they're drinking and you're not
people hate that land you dream so I had
to learn to find whatever the most [ __ ]
wine there was which is Riesling I think
okay so I get a Riesling little girly
wine tastes almost like apple juice take
a sip they go oh good he's drinking okay
good
yeah they don't notice me going through
you've gone through like one glass in
the time that someone else has gone
through a bottle not even a glass yeah a
glass yeah I guess that's for two hours
yeah but it looks like I'm drinking cuz
it's sitting in front of me and it's
less than what I got when I was served
to me so the oh good okay he's drinking
now I can relax now that someone else is
doing something I can relax which is the
exact opposite of my entire viewpoint of
life but that's our we're communal
creatures when mimetic
creatures as my friend George and
previous host said guest of the podcast
would say yet alcohols a weird one man
it triggers people in such bizarre ways
you totally ride this like there's
nothing else I picked up no one else is
shooting up heroin or getting it
- or going like going paleo or like
riding the bike to work and saying like
why are you not doing all of these
things people do that's changing you
know in some parts the world especially
in mine I don't know about I don't know
about England probably not but in my
part of the world - the Pacific
Northwest United States weed is becoming
like that now
oh you don't smoke weed people kind of
start to get surprised now because it's
become so prevalent and it's been it's
legal in most parts the United States
now maybe not most a lot yes
weed marijuana is starting to move in
that zone of alcohol where people there
they don't think something's wrong with
you don't smoke me but they are so I've
had people be surprised they don't it's
in this region do you think that that's
partly because you're a blogger an
author right one of those creative
e-types kind of probably pushing the
boundaries you maybe sound like the sort
of person that has that personality
probably yeah probably another is
another aspect is that I'm a libertarian
so they just expect that that's part of
the deal another one is people who know
my lifestyle sexually they go oh really
I'm shocked you don't smoke weed so
maybe it's a lot of factors that's a
good point and look at that if you if
you're sleeping with with multiple women
and not holding down monogamous
relationships making a stand presuming
people presuming that you may be making
a moral stand or some sort of virtue
stand with regards to the alcohol or the
weed which oh I get that a lot yeah it
doesn't seem is the case it's just a
lifestyle choice the same way as some
people don't like to wear blue or some
people don't like to drive stick like
this is just a lifestyle choice yeah
I've gotten that a lot people assume
that I'm Christian or Mormon or
something like that oh you must be
really religious you don't you don't
drink no no no I believe God but I'm not
religious so no so yeah I've definitely
gotten that yeah that's just part of
it's part of the culture I've learned to
accept you have to learn to accept the
oddness of your culture or else you're
gonna be pissed off all the time I want
to be so I can't do that tomorrow wanna
things bizarre because we're seeing but
seeing a substance go from being heavily
controlled to legalize for medical use
to like fragmented legalization across
the states in certain areas it is
illegal some it's legal for medicine
some it's totally legal recreationally
and we're observing the social
conditioning change in front of our eyes
mm-hmm
most Americans I don't know about most
half I forget the stats they always
change something like half or most of
Americans are on something anyway
prescription drugs things like that yeah
something like that the majority not the
vast majority but the majority of women
over 35 over 35 or 40 again I forget the
statistics are on some kind of mood
altering drug that's terrifying it's
really bad so here regardless you're
regardless regardless of weed you're
regardless is not a word mm-hmm my
grammar teacher regardless of we people
are on drugs anyway it's just it's part
of our culture which ones you manage and
it's getting worse as societal as
Western society continues its low
collapse you're going to see more and
more people going in that direction
anyway it's finding something that'll
make them not miserable
so it makes sense to me that more people
to be smoking weed or prescription drugs
heroin is a big epidemic Daly's the
United States here everyone's gone crazy
last four or five years gone nuts
desert I've seen it there's some really
interesting TV show so the UK we get
exposed to some of the stuff from
America but I think it's quite it's
quite difficult for us to fact-check not
fact-check but like a virtue check or
integrity check the content that we're
being fed because like I see a lot of
like so I'll see stuff from Netflix
that's like dope which is a really cool
Netflix documentary series two seasons
in each episode is in a different US
state yet u.s. city and one film crew
follows the cops and one film crew
follows the drug dealers and you see how
the two are trying to catch each other
and how they play off against each other
it's all or all the drug dealers have
got masks on and stuff like that it's
honestly fascinating TV program for
anyone in the UK that hasn't seen as
suggest that you go watch it now but
like stuff like that I don't know how
how realistic or how dramatized that is
but they talked about this fentanyl
crisis and they talked about like xanax
crises and all this sort of stuff
and yeah trying to judge it from the UK
because we don't have the big pharma
companies aren't allowed to advertise on
TV so that ask your doctor that stuff
doesn't exist right for us
I wouldn't either it's an epidemic but
it's not something you see out in the
world so you can go to a mall or walk
down the street United States you will
not be able to tell that people are on
whatever they're on or they're gonna
take something later that evening even
with a lot of the heroin people you
really can't tell so but when you get to
meet people and talk to people and get
in their lives you find out oh my god
really holy crap just women alone women
I've seen last four or five years the
heroin thing is it's it's nothing like
it was ten years ago it's a noticeable
difference and again that could be
regional or the United States is such a
big place it's very hard to say in the
United States everything's low area yeah
yeah I live between Seattle and Portland
so in that area is what I experience
when I'm not traveling I travel a lot so
it's hard to say the United States
that's why I like these people who set a
goal to like visit a hundred countries i
ice my glows based on cities cuz if
you've been to Beijing have you visited
China yeah
no you visited Bay if you went to New
York have you visited the United States
no you missin your kind of thing so yeah
it is it's it's really interesting and
again I just this is we talked about
this earlier I just not something I'm
into anymore I just I don't care yeah so
I I totally understand the people's
desire to escape feeling feeling
feelings is hard right like yeah some
feelings really suck yeah but I think it
shows that's why you have to learn to
manage your emotional states that's why
you have to learn emotional control I'm
telling guys this all the time well if
you don't there's [ __ ]
especially living today you'll get
you're gonna be screwed with the
internet just with the internet alone
very hard to be happy if you can't
manage your own emotions cuz every day
you'll be pissed off about something you
are constantly being triggered you're
right it's interesting to see the
difference between how and again this
may be localized within my area or my
social group in the UK but certainly for
me if you were to say tell me one person
that you know that is on a mood altering
drug I would actually struggle to be
able to find someone that really someone
that I know and I think what that shows
what that shows is the natural way to
deal with bad emotions can be dictated
by what firstly such as a societal
conditioning in your local peer group or
the people around you in the u.s. maybe
oh you feel bad that's a vicodin or you
should just go see your doctor or
whatever it might be right on top of
that as well obviously it's top-down
it's being broadcast at you like you
have a problem the solution the solution
is in a pill or a cream or additive as
you said that I just thought through in
my own head how many people I personally
know on something I came up with six
names I know a lot of people though so
maybe I'm not a good example but I as
I'm thinking I'm thinking of more or
seven people and the number of people I
personal on something even if it's a
prescription something yeah so my point
is that I I think I I wouldn't do how
many people who really need medication
slipped through the net in the UK by not
having this awareness about the fact
that prescription drugs could help and
how many people in the US are being
oversold on things that they don't need
because of this societal conditioning
and because of this stuff here
sure well that last aspect is most
people who take these drugs if you just
did basic things like get eight hours of
sleep drink a lot more water monitor
your hormones get your hormone tests
done meditate a little bit focus on
something you like have more sex you
just do those basic things all of a
sudden a lot of these symptoms not all
of them depends the person would go away
with no drugs and these would actually
enhance your life instead of causing
side effects but what I just said those
things those are hard that takes work
we're all right take a drug but pills a
pill super easy have you read lost
connections by Johann Hari no fantastic
book on depression highly recommended if
you've got a little depression or just
pressure in general depression in
general so he looks at the standard
model of depression that it's a
imbalance of chemicals in the brain and
send that to me when we're done talking
I'm injured
fantastic guy I cannot Johann if you're
listening he does tune in sometimes if
you're listening I'm gonna continue
hustling you come on because I need you
thank you man but it's fantastic book
really really interesting and he
identifies nine biological causes of
depression sorry seven biological seven
environmental causes of depression two
biological and the environmental ones
alike that's about that makes sense to
me seven out of nine that's about right
yes about what I would expect yeah and
he talks loss of connection to nature
loss of connection to a meaningful
future loss of connection to work loss
of connection to childhood trauma all of
these things and it's a very
comprehensive analysis of people and
it's very narrative based so again for
anyone who's listening who wants to
enlighten themselves and make themselves
a little bit better educated about why
depression occurs either in yourself or
in the people that are around you I
can't recommend it's the 80/20 book on
depression to me like just read it super
easy read a little bit long but super
easy read and and you got it man but
yeah the way that people deal with it
they just think America appears to have
and it's bad right because it reflects
on you guys as a nation people see
Americans as this quick fix
transactional transitory like lazy
people because of that culture which
isn't true in terms of the culture it's
just in terms of how people are dealing
with things and it's historically it has
not been true historically Americans
have been the hardest-working people on
earth historically right now we're
changing historically and there's a
deist still a decent percentage of us
who are not lazy but that's all changing
based on demographic factors and
economic factors and cultural factors
and all kinds of things what's changing
what do you think the trajectories going
still for you guys at the moment for
what moving forward with with that
particular I guess line of sight for
whether people are going to continue
whether there's going to be something a
change does there need to be a big
intervention there needs to be but there
won't be right where Americans are now
set on their path we Pete I mean I'm not
a historian but based on the stuff I
read over it a lot America as a nation
in relay
other nations Peaks somewhere around the
mid I believe the mid to late 1960s and
since then we've been on kind of on the
downslope especially if you compare us
to other nations it's not happy and that
is what's that is that happiness that is
one yeah it's economics economically
position in the world
our currency levels of happiness so you
now you have depression suicide has gone
up all this crazy stuff that's all
happened in my lifetime I was born in
1972 and so in my lifetime I have seen
my country and most other countries in
the Western world - I don't want just
pick on my country but I live here so I
see it yeah I have seen my country get
worse in literally every aspect except
for crime rates have gone way down and
technology has improved other than those
two things by every other measurement
you could find my country is worse off
when I was a kid from when I was a kid
to now and this is the first time
Americans have experienced this
historically if you are 47 year-old
American you would see your country if
you were born in the 1800's 1700s early
nineteen hundred's even mid 1900s you
would have seen your country grow and
improve even with problems we grew and
improved in the 20th century even though
a lots of problems so you but you would
have seen a net growth and so like for
example wages real wages for just infer
relation have been stagnant since I was
one year old and I'm almost 50 so I've
never seen wages increase in my country
as compared to inflation so in the 1970s
my dad was a lower income worker he made
a Lola he was a lower lower middle class
maybe even upper lower-class guy and he
he barely made me money but he was able
to in the 70s he was able to support a
family of seven he was able to stay at
home mom my wife my wife my mom and us I
had five siblings so the five of us yeah
and that was in the late 70s early 80s
today a guy that's not even possible for
a guy today in the United States you
couldn't even do that you have to make a
six-figure income or higher to maintain
all that stuff a low income guy can
barely even support himself a low income
guy today would struggle did he live on
his own and have a car in the United
States in most cities and most regions
so that
and that's the difference I've seen
since I grew up just in my lifetime yeah
I don't know man I don't know what I
don't know what the future's going to
store I think again for the UK we are a
little bit less despondent because
there's so much less turmoil like I look
at America especially American politics
and it looks like a sitcom that's how
our city is it is you're you are correct
the perception is reality it's a sitcom
okay it's been a sitcom for quite a
while this is nothing it's not with
Trump people think it started with Trump
it started long before Trump but yeah
it's a sitcom correct and yeah I see
that and I think for some reason maybe
it's just me mood rose rose tinted
glasses and some of the listeners may be
saying I'm completely wrong about this
by just the UK doesn't have that same
degree of turmoil we're not as we're
certainly not as polarized in terms of
the objectives yeah I agree with you and
I think that just that like that on its
own forces people when you have fewer
people at the ends of each spectrum
politically in terms of how they
identify with that particular kind of
thinking stance which is what become
right political stance is now not just
about politics it downstream from that
totally well that surely that's got to
affect your opinion on wheat surely
that's got to affect your opinion on
alcohol and and on pharmaceuticals and
blah blah blah blah taxes and all the
rest of it but for the UK people are a
lot less identified with that we got a
lot more rain to contend with
I think than you guys so there's a lot
more like umbrella putting up and
putting down and but like I don't know
it's is interesting I wonder how I'll be
there in I'll be there in October I
think maybe it'll see I'll be it'll
still be okay whether by the time you
get here I was reading him just before
we came on I was reading a news article
and it was talking about how to sell
apps to kids so is an advice piece for
app developers about the to trigger
points for getting apps to kids and
we're talking like under I think it's
like under 7 or under 8 and it was like
there's two different types of people
that you can sell to one of them are the
kids and then get them to kind of pester
the parents and the other ones the
parents I I was looking at this article
like
I can't even believe that this is a
thing that in whose right mind should
anyway its harga ting well I'm why
targeting apps are kids money yeah are
you surprised you're really surprised
you don't be surprised not surprised not
surprised you are right not surprised
but I am I'm concerned I'm biased in
this area I'm an extreme capitalist so
I'm very biased in this area but still
no one should be surprised
yeah that's again this is part of the
world we live in sure yeah you are right
so we touched on it before your
particular views on monogamy and dating
and stuff like that the listeners at
home as I mentioned before we started
we've we've never had anybody on who has
been a polyamory advocate or whatever
you would even I don't even know how you
cast yourself so can you just take us
from the beginning talk to us about your
your stance and about what it means and
stuff like that so the non monogamy I
don't call it polyamory because
polyamory is a segment of non-monogamy
so polyamory is very specific polyamory
is when you are dating multiple women
and they are dating multiple men so it's
kind of this big happy group kind of
falling all over each other which is
fine that's one segment of Domino so I
call it non-monogamy a it's a little
less threatening than polyamory and B
it's more inclusive of every all the
different types of non monogamy cool so
non monogamy is not a core I mean it
sounds like it is sometimes depending
what you read of what I write it's not
the core of what I talk about it is a
important slice of the pie so it really
starts with long term masculine
happiness and so the way men work and
women are different but the way men work
is the freer you are on a given day to
day basis meaning you can wake up every
morning and do whatever you want
whenever you want with whomever you want
without having to check in with anybody
or get anyone's permission if you the
more the closer you are that condition
the happier you tend to be so you will
be happier if you have your own business
generally speaking than if you have a
corporate wage job because you have more
freedom you will be happier if you're
allowed to have sex multiple women
whatever you want then if you're only
allowed to have sex with one woman at
least long-term and that's the way
you're wired you can't control this
that's just the way you are
there are rare and usual exceptions but
they're the rare unusual accept
so if you look at when I talk about
things like alpha 2.0 that is an entire
lifestyle you're gearing your entire
life around maximum freedom in all the
seven areas of your life the two core of
those for a man being financial and
sexual you start there you start with
those two core areas because those help
you with all the other areas once those
are in a baseline and so yeah if you go
into the woman part you need to be
allowed to phone number one you need to
have sex a new movement now as guys not
having sex so that's not gonna make you
happy long term you're a guy so assuming
you're having sex you need to be allowed
to have sex with multiple women because
long term you're not gonna be happy with
having sex with just one woman short
term you will you can make it work for a
while a year and a half two years three
years whatever you are every guy's
different but long term and the models I
talk about are all long-term models that
lasts for the rest of your life not just
in your 20s and early 30s but your 40s
50s 60s and so on these are long-term
models so if you want a long-term
happiness model you've got to work get
in there in some way your ability to
have sex with multiple women if you
choose to and there's four or five
different ways you can do that we could
talk about those if you want but that's
that's where the non-monogamy comes from
it's not about non-monogamy it's about
long term freedom which creates long
term happiness for dudes why do you
think men and women are so different
what's specifically obviously
genetically you've alluded to the fact
that man's genetic predisposition is to
push his genes as far as is possible
however it would appear based on some of
the people who I've spoken to
anthropologists evolutionary biologists
that pair-bonding has to occur the
reason the gestation is nine months and
that sex is a long process a pleasurable
process the fact that women don't have
visual ovulation all of these sort of
things the fact that conception is
actually relatively fairly tough for
humans compared with some other animals
yes all of that leads towards pair
bonding pair bonding needs to occur
because the infant is pretty much
dependent on the the mother of the
family but specifically the mother for
the
first 10 to 15 years and you need to
have a father around to protect that
particular pairing or however many
children there is that particular family
unit you need to have the father around
or else everybody dies because if a
Jaguar comes while you've got a mother
all accurate okay so so now here's the
problem this is where people get
confused everything you just said is
scientifically accurate and I read about
this stuff myself so you're that's
absolutely true human beings this and
this is where people get messed up human
beings are pair-bonding creatures but
they are not sexually monogamous
creatures there are two those are two
different things so you can be I'm a
perfect example I am pair-bonded I'm
married I am pair bonded to one woman
who I share my life with who I love I
don't love anyone else I don't want to
be with anyone else
I don't want to spend the rest of my
life anyone else just her and her with
me so we are pair bonded but I'm allowed
to go out on the side and get laid
whenever I want whenever I choose with
whomever I like there's a few ground
rules I agree to but beyond that I'm
still allowed to be non-monogamous even
though I'm pair-bonded so what happens
is people quote these scientific facts
and they are backs absolutely true and
they say see we're monogamous well then
why is it we have a 76% north of 76
percent divorce rate why do we have a 77
percent infidelity rate if we're
monogamous
we are pair bonding creatures we are not
monogamous creatures so again if you
want to be long-term happy and I realize
this is difficult because you're gonna
run into all kinds of suicidal
programming and societal conditioning to
tell you this is wrong you're gonna have
to be long-term in your life not when
your new 20s I tell guys you shouldn't
have a girlfriend - you're in your 30s
my opinion so once you're an older guy
yes you need be pair-bonded but not
monogamous so that means you sit down
with your special someone and you
explain it to her like an adult hey I
love you I want to be with you I want to
be with anyone else and I'm a human
being and I'm a guy and that means a B
and C we could lie to each other like
teenagers and say well we're loved we'll
be together forever and we'll never want
to sleep with anyone else because we're
in love and Disney's and Narnia and
unicorns and roses and [ __ ] or we can be
adults and say let's be together let's
figure out a plan
we can integrate this into our
lifestyles so I could be happy and you
could be long-term happy because I'm
happy and we avoid all these problems or
at least most the problems at normal
couples have the seventy six percent
divorce rate people I mean the fact that
there is such a high divorce rate people
just presume I guess if you just if you
think about your if you to ask the lay
person on the street why is the divorce
rate so high it's it would be maybe some
kind of wistful heritage thing about
while it wasn't that way in my parents
day my parents are still together
perhaps right they just cheated right
people stayed married and they and the
men mostly men cheated so they still
weren't monogamous
okay so long-term marriage and marriage
working yeah well they've been married
for 47 years he's never cheated maybe he
hasn't but the odds are I've talked to a
lot of old guys guys my grandfather's
age guys their 90s World War two guys
these guys were married and they stay
married they were not monogamous they
cheated you've seen I don't know if
you've seen the American show Mad Men
about Americans in the 60s it's it was
the standard model back then you cheated
that's just what you did when you're a
guy women too not as much but they did
do why is the divorce rate changed
because women are now allowed to do
whatever they want so back in the olden
days in like the 1950s which a lot of
guys in my world the red Pierre met the
vertical manosphere will go back to
women weren't allowed to get divorced so
women would actually go into a court in
the 40s 30s 50s and say when I divorce
my husband and the judges say what the
hell get yep you can't get to get back
to your husband next case or and or they
were an outlaw or they couldn't do it
financially they couldn't support
themselves they need to be married so
we've died and if they got divorced
they're their religious family would
disown them so all these factors we
don't respect this are now gone women
are now encouraged to get divorced now
it's the opposite
well you've become more financially
independent more secular and more
accepting I guess of divorce as a whole
yeah and yeah I mean not and it'll get
worse and it'll get worse the divorce
rate will increase you're gonna see soon
in the next decade you're gonna see 90
plus percent divorce rates
people are very slow to figure this out
read about this a lot they don't want to
admit this system doesn't work anymore
so they're just gonna keep getting
married keep getting divorced keep
screwing up their kids keep getting
financially raped keep cheating on each
other and yelling at each other and it's
gonna be a while before human beings
finally go you know we should probably
pick a different system this isn't
working
it's gonna be awhile unfortunately the
stats I mean you know there's not much
that I can say about the fact that more
than three-quarters of the people who
get married end up getting divorced as
far as I was aware maybe it's a UK start
I think it was more than 50 but no
matter what the start is if there's a
more likelihood a high likelihood that
you're going to get divorced then stay
together
it's a worrying statistic no matter what
your views on monogamy are it's pretty
worrying statistic yeah it is yeah it's
terrible yeah instead people should
figure out how to stay together like two
normal human beings the way human beings
actually work instead of the way human
beings work in a Disney fairy tale well
we're gonna get married and we're gonna
be in love forever we're never gonna
[ __ ] anyone else because we're loved and
that's because Snow White
yeah what were you saying at the
beginning about humans being mimetic
creatures and about us taking a lot of
societal conditioning swallowing that
red pill as you've alluded to is a
difficult thing to do when everyone else
around you hasn't right like when you
you're that's the big problem with guys
in my audience I think one of the
biggest questions I get I don't know any
other men like me how do I if I tell my
mom she's gonna get mad at me yeah
that's the big challenge
I've been working last year-and-a-half
on that specific problem for guys to
plug into more communities and things
like that but yes that's the problem
that's the problem
because I it's very rare these days now
ten years ago to get this but these days
it's very rare for a man to say oh no
traditional monogamous marriage works
great as long as you do these new things
and every guy should do that very rare a
guy even a hardcore right-wing
evangelical Christian even those guys
don't say that they say yeah it doesn't
work but I'm not gonna do this and
there's nothin on monogamy well but that
no okay but that's fine if you don't you
have to like it but the alternative
doesn't work you're pointing at
something that doesn't work so you've
either got something that doesn't work
or you've got something that works but
makes you emotionally uncomfortable for
a while so those are your two options
I'd rather pick this because I want to
be happy I'm not gonna pick something
doesn't work so one of the first things
that comes to mind for me when I think
about a non-typical non-monogamous
relationship as you're a non-typical
relationship which is non-monogamous is
what do you do about the kids what do
you do about raising children in that
sort of an environment I know I
personally know about the sea as in
right this second I know let's see seven
couples six couples and I've known many
other couples six or seven I've to think
about that for a minute who are married
who live together no one really knows
what kind of lifestyle they lead other
than close friends and people like me
and they have kids as a matter of fact
when I was married the first time back
when I was young and stupid was married
a thousand years ago I was married
traditionally and monogamously and it
didn't work because she got depressed
and started taking pills and when we
were married while I was married for
literally four houses down on my street
I didn't know this until after I'd moved
away
there was a married couple with two
little kids who played with my kids who
had a wide open marriage I had no idea
as far as I know they're still married
this is decades ago they were and they
were the happiest couple on the block
and they had kids now no one knew that's
why I didn't know didn't know till later
just kind of for the grapevine what I
actually called him up and said it's
true and I don't want to freak out here
was it true that there's a God and and
my old thing my old joke to myself is if
I had just sat down and top that guy for
an hour before I got married the first
time incorrectly in my view it would
have saved me a lot of time and ever so
you can have kids you just can't I have
kids I raised kids under this model I
just got married remarried the C year
and a half ago yes and so my daughter
and my son were little when I was living
this way you just there are rules you
don't parade women around your kids
obviously you need to show your kids
some level of consistency you need to be
an example you don't go out and telling
everybody in their school or all your
friends and family that what you're
doing if you don't want to people have
to know what you're doing
that's there's no requirement there you
just have to be realistic about your
sexual desires
so yeah you can have kids a lot of
people have kids and again if I say have
an open marriage and have kids
immediately your societal programming
goes well okay fine you can you can live
your life like two plus two equals five
if you want that's fine cool you won't
be very happy a lot of problems you can
do that fine I'd rather live two plus
two equal four even if I don't really
like forward for emotionally bothers me
initially that's how I look at it so
some of the listeners may have heard us
talk about him before but Aubry Marcus I
don't know whether you know who that is
I've heard that name but that's all I
know I've heard that name so he's the
CEO or founder of on it which is a so
yeah supplement company that Joe Rogan
is a partner of very big very successful
I haven't actually gone spoken that much
about aubray but people who read my
tweets will have seen that recently had
to unsubscribe from his newsletter
Albury and his wife Whitney who is a
very attractive Ultimate Fighting
Championship type ring announcer
commentator type woman soon fear very
ver but they are in a I think it's
classed as a polyamorous or an open
relationship I there's probably a degree
of granularity that you would be able to
discern from what's going on that I I'm
not going to be able to get to but and
he talks about this experience when his
wife brought home another man for the
first time and the way that he felt and
then he talked about the first time that
he had sex with another woman and he
said both of those situations every time
that his wife brought another man home
he was dry retching on the floor and it
took him four months to get over oh my
god no so this is Ian's this is in his
email newsletter one of the things I can
say about all Bray is he's very candid
right so he's emailing you as being
honest that's very cool of him he's
being honest that's great we need more
people like that actually so I applaud
him for that I I'm one of the few guys
in the world I think literally who talk
about my non-monogamous exploits and my
experiences under my own name with my
own picture and it's me yeah
there should be a lot more people than
just me there are people I know with
audiences my
eyes are much larger who don't talk
about this Solis he's doing that but
yeah one of the challenges with this are
guys who do this wrong so everything
he's describing I would never do in my
marriage that doesn't work yeah I don't
want to be mean to this guy I have no
idea but yeah fire away you are you're
an expert in this particular field or as
close to an expert as I can get hold of
so we're gonna find out what you think
you have to sit down you have to sit
down and be realistic about what will
piss you off and what will not piss you
off before you actually get into
relationship and before you even have
these discussions so that's number one a
lot of people don't even do that they
say okay we're open a lot of more like
left-wing like hippyish type people huh
we're sexually free it'll be great and
then yeah and then their wife brings a
guy to the house and has sex with him oh
my god no you have to you have to know
your own parameters and be self-aware
first what am i capable of doing what am
I not capable of doing if XY and Z
happen would I be able to handle that or
not and you need to think that stuff
through and even if you need to write it
down you figure all this stuff that I
get them on paper first I'm not I'm not
a super jealous guy but there are things
my wife could do that would that would
make me not retch on the floor but
things like Jesus what the hell so you
have to be aware of those things first
then your partner has to be aware of her
things so she has to get into her head a
little bit because she's not going to
tell you and figure out what her
parameters are internally and every
woman is very different so for example
my wife is more comfortable if she's
more aware of the specific women I'm
playing with on the side whereas my last
serious relationship the girlfriend I
had before her she was the opposite if
she didn't know she knew I was doing
machine no any details he was very happy
she thought it was fine when she found
out details or when I told her things
she would get really pissed off so every
woman is very different about this so
that's the first level then the second
level is you sit down and you discuss
the ground rules again before you get
too serious once you're already moved in
and married and now you to discuss
ground rules that's too late so my wife
and I had a very long detailed
discussion I called the OLT our talk I
have all structured for this stuff this
was several years ago and I laid out all
the negatives of being married to me and
non-monogamy was pissed off I
like four five and that was just one
matter fact the one she was scared about
was that I work a lot I work every day
she's like well you didn't care about
that on and on because I'd already been
doing it the whole time she met me so
she was used at that point it was more
like well you're gonna work a lot you
never gonna spend of time it was more of
that kind of stuff but you lay all that
stuff out and then you lay out the
ground rules and you're very specific
about the ground rules based on what
you're capable of and what you think
you're not capable of emotionally you
just don't go hog-wild and and bring men
over so he should have known Hey look
look wife before she's my wife hey
girlfriend who are thinking about
getting serious we're gonna be
non-monogamous here the parameters but
here's what you can't do you can't bring
guys over and [ __ ] him on my couch that
I'll throw up you gotta be honest about
that stuff even he didn't do and a lot
of people don't do that in and and I
yeah it damages the cause when that
happens I see that a lot of it reads to
me the the the emails and the stuff that
I've seen from him and his semi diary he
uses his email list sometimes it almost
feels a little bit like a journal so the
transparency from Aubree I I really
admire yeah it's great it was I had to
unsubscribe or Brayfield listening I
apologize but it was it was - woke like
it was so woke and everything was like
hyper woke each email that came through
and I think well he's big those are the
kind of people who screw this up
people who go too far with the left wing
woke this stuff and we're we're
creatures of nature and it doesn't
matter and no it does matter it does
matter to certain people's you have to
be aware of these things there are there
are boundaries of these things now if
you're not serious then you can do
whatever you want so I talk about I have
there's there's different types there's
FBS which are non serious there's n ltrs
worth serious but not committed and
there's olt i which is like a girlfriend
to your wife
so there's levels and there's less rules
as you go further over to this side of
the scale you can do whatever you want
over here over here if you want to be
pair-bonded you've got to commit to some
level of rules it's not it's not a
free-for-all it's not going to work it's
not how you and binkies work
unfortunately be nice what they did but
they don't yes I think what it seems to
me so albury is a big like psychedelic
warrior right like he's big into his
mushrooms and his D
and he goes away with the Charmin and
and gets like not surprised I guess and
I think yeah it fits the model right
yeah what I think what I think he was
potentially doing with this was almost
seeing it as like a rite of passage I
think he had seen this particular
prescription for non-monogamy in
whatever model it was that he thought he
was going to adhere to and then him and
his then-wife
were going to fit their life around this
prescription as opposed to having it be
emergent which is what you're talking
about he had seen okay this is what
non-monogamy is therefore I'm gonna
stick to and I think he talks about I
think it's in his book seize the day he
talks about how brought this guy home
and it was like this for the first X
number of weeks or months or times or
whatever that it happened oh my god and
then and then he had a breakthrough and
you sound the terminology for
breakthrough is taken from when people
smoked DMT right it's that you have this
breakthrough experience so you take a
hero dose of mushrooms and you break
through and I think he was maybe trying
to layer a psychedelic framework or like
fit non-monogamy into a psychedelic
matrices like that was what he was
trying to fit into to woke your right to
to up that's it could be summarized in
its last objectivity and he's lost
reality you need to be objective about
these things I mean and that's that's an
example it's an interesting example of
it going the other way most people are
on the other side more the right-wing
side including people who are considered
left-wing people the marriage looks like
this and a relationship looks like this
and it better look like this or you're a
sinner or I'm never gonna get that
usually people on the other side of
irrationality he's on this side of the
rash there's a rational zone in the
middle between those two extremes you've
got to be rational about how human
beings are but you also have to be
rational and objective and self-aware
enough to know what your limits are and
every guy is different and every woman
is different yeah it's an interest in
one month it's an interest in my I mean
he's this the penultimate email to the
one that
subscribe from the title was me and
Whitney nearly split up today and that's
him and his him and his wife and I'm
like I appreciate it yeah it's a little
too much information you should be yeah
it's the woken this man likes I
appreciate the generous Baron C and I
genuinely do think and it plays into his
shtick right it's part and parcel his
thing but I like man like if you and
your wife are on the verge of splitting
up don't use that as your [ __ ] weekly
newsletter content you know like that
true that's that's a piece of advice and
another piece of advice like he talks in
the [ __ ] first a second line of this
of his Instagram post from the same day
was like um Whitney left to go to Texas
to see her boyfriend today so that is
this is an example of what you were talk
about early about what polyamory is the
difference being polyamory and an open
relationship okay so in my view and this
is this is not a fact more than my
opinion but I'm pretty sure I'm right
about this if you want to be pair-bonded
that person shouldn't have other
boyfriends because that's not pair
bonding so if your wife has a boyfriend
or if you're married and you have
another girlfriend on the side a
girlfriend that's not bear bond yeah he
has that too oh yeah yes he has two
girlfriends he has two girlfriends okay
so if you've used these as real
girlfriends real emotional meaning and
commitment to these women in addition to
his wife that's not pair bonding that's
something else that's that's more
polyamory so that be a polyamorous
marriage which I don't I'm against I
think that's a very bad idea
well I think polyamory is great if you
are not pair bonded so for many years in
under my parlance to be MLT are so I had
multiple ml Tiaras for years and it was
great but I didn't have a girlfriend
they were all women I would date I was
dating and I really liked and I liked on
an emotional level but they weren't a
girlfriend once you have a girlfriend
that's pair bonding so if you have
multiple girlfriends I've talked to a
lot of guys about this hundreds of guys
about this almost never have I seen that
work long term to have multiple in the
Western world I mean you could move to
Saudi Arabia or do something else but in
the Western world having multiple
girlfriends or multiple wives or
something to that equivalent
it doesn't work long-term the West you
can't do that if you're gonna be
pair-bonded you need to be pair-bonded I
am with you I have no other girlfriends
or wives except you I'm allowed to go
get laid on the side these are not my
girlfriends these are women who are my
friends FB switch is friend with
benefits it's a friend not a girlfriend
so I have an oil TR I have a wife and I
have FPS they're not my girlfriends
they're just my buddies and we have sex
and that's it we don't go to dates we
don't spend the week together I already
have that with my wife that's more
that's a more long-term sustainable
model I understand I think obray if you
listening we got some advice for you man
get in touch with Caleb ill ill ill do a
little rundown here maybe maybe give you
a little bit of a he needs to downgrade
his girlfriends to FPS he needs to make
his wife his only wife and his only
girlfriend and she needs to make that
kind of commitment too and if she
doesn't want to they should get divorced
and they should his date that we could
actually sleep now it's sustainable
I might read I'll sign up to his
newsletter and I'll reply and I'll give
him yeah even the too long didn't read
from the podcast much so one of the
things that I've been thinking in the
back of my mind and I can't
fantastically put myself in the mind of
a female but to the girls that are
listening I would love to hear what your
thoughts are about this whether or not
you would have ever considered this or
whether it's so kind of visceral and
stomach-turning
because of the way that you naturally
consider couples and partnerships to be
that it's difficult to almost put
yourself into this situation but I think
certainly one of the things that that
will come to mind for many people when
and I'm very empathetic right like my my
empathy is crippling so for me to think
about the way the probably nicer person
than me though you're probably nice good
yeah but too nice sometimes and
unfortunately people like people if they
realize that if they realize how
empathetic you are it's a big big
advising yeah and it causes you to move
slow as well like you when you're super
concerned about how your actions are
going to affect other people it often
causes you to to drop into inertia so
but we all have our shortcomings in our
advantages right like there's people out
there who might not have the empathy but
I have a whole host of other issues they
got a deal that's me I have very I have
extremely I've been told and then
they're right extremely low empathy III
barely give a [ __ ] about anything so the
advantages I can move very quickly I can
get a lot of things done I have a very
organized very good life the
disadvantages I can hurt people's
feelings if I'm not careful people close
to me so I so as a as you grow you have
to learn to mitigate those weaknesses so
you have to learn to become stay
empathetic but not let it hamper you and
I have to learn how to be more
empathetic yeah right
yeah its engine is it's is interesting
how you do that do you find within the
non-monogamy community a people skew to
less empathetic
I'm gonna guess maybe no Reno I don't I
rented people who are more like you okay
that's interesting especially the
polyamory people I'm really not in that
group yeah I mean they're not monogamy
so they're my brothers I love them but
but I'm not a polyamorous guy yep so but
yes especially the polyamory world yes
much more empathetic guys yes absolutely
that's interesting but yeah so to try
and put myself into the mind of a girl
thinking about this particular situation
certainly one of the problems that you
may come up against and I'm gonna guess
you will have a format for this or a
structure for this that exists where you
have a man who does want to be able to
have other partners outside of his main
relationship but that which is for men
but go ahead but the the girl in the
relationship has no desire to be with
other men or normal yeah but that I
think what this describe the norm okay
well at least in the earlier parts of
the relationship you just describe the
norm he wants to play around and she
doesn't doesn't want to or doesn't want
to yet what that leads to people
thinking and what it certainly leads to
me thinking is that there's there's some
kind of imbalance unfairness between the
two that somehow the open non-monogamous
relationship would work more easily or
would somehow be more balanced is a way
to put it if both partners had other
things going on
that's true but if one partner doesn't
want those things which happens all the
times happened to me a lot yeah then
fine
the as long as she is allowed to because
that's one of the first questions she's
gonna throw at your face when you start
describing these things to her
the very first thing that's gonna tumble
out of her mouth is well can i buck
other guys either she doesn't want to
and has no intention to and thinks it's
gross
if she were to do that she's still gonna
say that and if you say well then you're
out if you say yes if you really want to
do that yes of course then she goes oh
cool so I mean so then we lead on to the
next thing which is that for men and
again this is evolutionary conditioning
for men
allowing your partner to sleep with
other men provokes an incredibly
visceral response incredibly and if you
want to have your cake you need to I'm
going to guess that it's probably a
pretty difficult sell to say our
relationship is going to be non
monogamous but only for me and not
long-term sustainable okay so if I've
never seen that I've seen guys try that
I've never seen it lasts more than nine
months why think that she's a humorous
man try that in the Western world guys
able to sleep around girl isn't yeah so
he's literally says I'm gonna [ __ ] other
women you can only [ __ ] me and she's
like and he's a strong alpha male and
she's a little willow a little
submissive girl and she goes okay and
within nine months they either break up
or she bangs someone else just to get
just to make it even yeah and to balance
a lot just to get back at him yeah so
for guys I mean like for me personally
again maybe I'm two blue pillow or maybe
I haven't taken the red pill yet enough
for this I struggle to see a situation
in which I would be able to stomach
somebody that I love sleeping with
someone else with my allowance with my
grace so there are several answers to
that answer number one and they're in
their different areas so answer number
one is a significant percentage of women
who are not super young so if she's
under the age of 23 she's gonna have sex
other guys that's that's what young
girls do if she's older a significant
percentage
my experience in my anecdotal experience
but I have a lot of anecdotal experience
it's around 40 to 50 percent won't sleep
the other men even if they have the
opportunity to they don't want to they
think that's gross so even though you're
sleeping other women they say okay
you're a man you're a barbarian that's
all men are but I don't do that I'm
appropriate I'm a Christian or I'm at
this or I'm at that so I'm not gonna do
that so that's one number two if she
does women are not like men
and so what men do is they negative
fantasize about well well if she if I'm
allowed to go out and have sex
constantly the other women and I'm gonna
constantly do that for the rest of my
life oh no she's gonna constantly do
that no she doesn't
women go through horny phases they go
through non-sexual phases they go
through all kinds of different phases so
if she does she might do it for a few
months and then stop and never do it
again or maybe do it once every ten
years or once every few years off and on
very rarely she's not gonna do it
consistently like I do it like you would
do it cuz we're men men are not like
women that's the second answer third
answer is you should train yourself to
get to the point where you care less so
if you're a jealous person it's gonna be
harder for you to be a happy person so
if you have this thing where a lot of
guys are like this there's there's guys
were really jealous guys were moderately
jealous and guys who don't really don't
give a [ __ ] so they're really jealous
guys if they even see a guy comment on
her Facebook page or they hear a thing
on Instagram go off on her phone and
they just go into a rage you have a
problem there's something wrong with you
you need to fix you don't say well I'm a
man and that's just how I am and and
quote a bunch of you know evolutionary
psychology about how I need to you know
protect my women and I'm not gonna you
can you can get me on that science you
want your there's something wrong with
you in terms of your long-term happiness
if you're that angry and that jealous so
if you are on a scale from one to ten
you're 12 if you visualize a woman you
like having meaningless sex with a beta
male who's no competition to you wearing
a condom if that just drives you insane
then it's it behooves you in terms of
being a man and being a happy man and
you approve of yourself to get that 12
down to a 6 or a 7 or a 5 or somewhere
in there drop it down you should do that
anyway regard
you would plan on being monogamous for
the rest of your life you would do that
anyway you shouldn't go through life
being that touchy about these things
because that's all I see all the time
and that's what a woman's biggest
complaints about guys is they start
seeing them and all sudden the guy
starts to just put all these fences and
walls around them and the woman's
attraction for the man goes down
she's like a look now for a while she
likes it because that means he likes me
but after a while oh my god kill me and
that's one of the reasons why 75% of
boyfriend-girlfriend relationships are
terminated by the female because the
only get stylist is not the statistic
that's the stat 3/4 3/4 of
boyfriend-girlfriend relationships are
ended by the woman and 70 to 80 percent
depending on the study you look at least
the United States of divorces are
initiated by the female so women like
getting into relationships women hate
staying in relationships it's not what
they like you could argue speak you
could argue that the girl is ending the
relationship because they potentially
found out that the man had cheated
that's a huge percentage of them yes and
one of the reasons I'm being able to do
this you can do this now especially now
if a woman starts complaining about this
if you starts to explain this to women
when you first start verbalizing it
oh you can't [ __ ] other girls not what a
relationship looks like all you have to
do I've done this with many women
including my wife when I met her all you
have to do is say you look at her and
you say every boyfriend you've ever had
of a decent period of time has cheated
on you right and they go and that's it
you're in you're done that that covers
so much of it because they know monogamy
doesn't work so that's the fourth answer
is the fourth answer is what is your
alternative your alternative is
something that doesn't work that we know
for sure doesn't work it's not like
maybe this might work we know for sure
the odds are overwhelming that it
probably won't work so by saying I can't
do this again you're going back to a
system that doesn't work thank you yeah
well that's those are my four answers of
that I think a lot of people because of
the visceral reaction that you'll get
maybe the dry retching on the floor or
just the sensation that people get both
guys and girls when you think about you
know to the people that are in
relationships who are listening just for
a second put yourself in the mind and
think what would happen if you tried to
have
an open relationship or a non-monogamous
relationship where you were allowed to
sleep with other people but you had to
put up with your partner sleeping as
someone else it evokes such a very very
visceral response because I think that
is a hurdle so many people will struggle
to get over and I'm gonna guess
potentially more guys will struggle to
get over that hurdle of allowing the
partner to sleep with other people
great even girls yeah yeah no not maybe
that is correct guys have much heart
much harder probably there's some women
do kill women are accustomed to men
sleeping around throughout all of human
history so they're kind of used to it
they don't like it but they're more it's
men who have a problem with it
interesting but yeah I mean thought
that's why the divorce rates gonna
continue to get worse because what you
just said what's working what where
people are doing now isn't working but
the alternative is so horrible they're
gonna keep going back to what isn't
working over and over and over unless
your goal in life and there are a few
men who say this move but not many
unless your goal in life is to have
cereal short-term monogamous
relationships for the rest of your life
so in other words if you tell me hey man
my goal is to have a girlfriend and I'll
have her for about a year and a half two
years and I'll break up with her you'll
be monogamous then I'll get a new
girlfriend
and I'll date her for about a year and
I'll have a new girlfriend nine times
out of the rest of my life for the rest
of your life if you say look I'm cool
doing that until in my 40s 50s 60s 70s
and you really say that with honesty
then you could ignore everything I'm
saying cuz that work other than that if
you have something long-term you're
gonna have to embrace a model that is
something other than what doesn't work
so as a bookend question - what has been
a really interesting discussion I'd love
to hear your thoughts on what you think
is the optimal setup for a relationship
in life so we've talked about you've
you've had multiple long-term partners
moving through would it would you have
preferred in a different iteration of
the world where you could control
everything that occurred within it do
you think it's optimal to have a what I
can't remember the MLF B or whatever it
was Oh ltr' there's one wife or
girlfriend me yes
is it optimal if you can to have
for sixty years thirty years however
long from mid-30s until whatever or from
future but optimal as and how human
beings are now for you if you were to
say to someone this is what I think is
for a broad cross-section of people the
best way to do things
yes for a broad cross-section of men but
not all men because they're exceptions
all these rules yeah there are some men
who should never be para bond there are
small percentage of men who should never
have a girlfriend they should just go
bang chicks and date and into their 60s
and 70s and there's a but that's an
exception yes for a broad cross-section
of people the least bad scenario because
I don't want to say best because there's
problems with work there are problems
with the models I'm talking about yes
everything you talk about our there's
our accurate criticisms the least bad
system is a long-term pair-bonded wife
or girlfriend however you want to term
it assuming you're over the age of 35
cuz I tell guys don't don't settle down
to women - you're at least 35 that's the
same at least at 35 so s assuming you're
35 or older you have a long term decades
long wife or girlfriend that you are
really good with and you're very
complimentary with and compatible with
and you are allowed to get sex on the
side within ground rules these are not
your girlfriends this is more casual
friendly sex when you need it as a man
and she is allowed to - and the older
she gets the less you'll do it she may
not do it at all she gets older that's
the least bad scenario for the broadest
cross-section of people yes because that
is that what I just described is doable
long term what is not doable long term
is we're gonna be married
you're never gonna touch anyone else for
the rest of your [ __ ] life and I
won't either and you roll your eyes as
you're saying it when you're a guy I
promise I won't either honey and we're
never gonna get divorced we're never
gonna split up that's not long-term
sustainable because that is a
fundamental violation of everything in
which all the ways in which you were
designed as a man and as a woman that's
why it doesn't work okay so I'm gonna
finish off with the question which is
you've got the monogamy which is the
traditional relationship approach which
you've just identified that and then
you've got all braids relationship which
is a rehabber wife and the wife's going
to have
which one Holly yeah that's a
polyamorous marriage which one is the in
your eyes the least effective which were
neither of those are long-term
sustainable which one's gonna fail first
here is how long has he been married I'm
not sure I don't know here's here's what
you can you can grit your teeth and be
monogamous to a wife for a long time I
did it for nine years and I'm a really
high sister so you can do it when men
and women can grit their teeth and
suffer through shitty marriages a lot of
people can do that they did that all
throughout the 50s and 60s and all that
good stuff so you can have a marriage
traditional monogamous marriage that
lasts a long time it won't last forever
that's not how you're designed and if it
does last forever someone's cheating and
someone's putting up with it but
someone's going to encounter in the
polyamorous marriage someone's going to
encounter a problem that is to the
relationship if he's retching on the
floor because there's a man [ __ ] his
wife in his house how is that long-term
sustainable it's not I can't do it well
I mean I whereas the guy who has a wife
at home and he cheats on her and hopes
he doesn't get caught you can stretch
that out for a long time so not forever
but you could stretch that out your
people some people make it last of their
entire lives right and that's fine but
that's not monogamous so that's why I
would view dysfunctional non-monogamy
your non-monogamous because you're
cheating you're having sex with multiple
people you're just pretending you're not
so now you're dealing with drama and
lying and all kinds of other problems
that are dysfunctional to your core
relationship with your wife and again my
wife if you're an empathetic individual
as I am the the times that I have
cheated in past relationships have
caused such second order third order
fourth order effect guilt and then
self-referential guilt and then you know
all of those things feelings of lower
degree of virtue lower degree of
integrity all of those sorts of things
that for me I was like well that's
that's not not a workable model cheating
being in a relationship and cheating is
not a workable model for me I not if you
want to be happy no not if you want to
be happy I've talked a lot of guys about
that model and that's they tell me
exactly what you're saying or vary or
they're terrified they're constantly
worried they're gonna get caught they
have multiple phones and multiple
accounts and all that good stuff
is not a long-term sustainable model if
happiness is your objective now if you
say to me and there's a few men who say
this I don't care about being long-term
happy I don't give a [ __ ] about that I
want to live my life this way yeah you
might be happier than me I don't care
great then go ahead and cheat but if
your objective is long-term happiness
you are correct you can't adopt a
cheating model long-term you've got to
figure out something else that is more
long-term sustainable even if it makes
you uncomfortable during the first few
months or a year or two you try it
that's interesting
Caleb for the listeners at home we want
to find out a little bit more maybe some
people think of it's a an interesting
discussion that I want to read a bit
more about why would you direct them I
have a lot of websites the easiest place
to go be Caleb Jones comso C al EBS and
boy Jones calm that's what kind of the
central hub of all my websites yeah most
a lot of my content is business and
location dependent come and all that
good stuff - again when monogamy is a
segment of what I talk about in terms of
masculine that I can't talk
masculine lifestyle design yeah I got
you well Caleb it's been it's been
really interesting I hope that we have
opened some people's eyes to a
alternative approach to relationships I
think certainly for me over the last few
years I've seen people talk about non
monogamy in different versions as we've
gone through today increasingly I do
wonder what the trajectory of that's
going to be I wonder whether people are
going to dig their heels in as divorce
rates continue to go up I wouldn't know
whether people are going to dig their
heels into the existing model more or
whether more people will begin to
migrate across to non-monogamy I think
you're gonna see a lot of both
everything gets a polarized mind but
it's been it's been really fascinating
thank you so much for your time you bet
a time catch later on
[Music]
you